Now let's see what is involved in making the
actual calls between the client and the server. And you
will see that all the kernel copying overheads are
eliminated in the actual calls. What the client stub does
on the client side is when the client makes
the call is that through, the clients tab is going to
take the arguments and put those arguments into the a
stack, ignore this result for a minute, so that the
stub is going to, the client stub is going to prepare the
a stack, with the arguments of the call, and then in
the a stack, you can only pass arguments by value,
not by reference. And the reason is that this A stack,
I mentioned to you is mapped into the client address
space and shortly, it's going to be mapped into the, it is,
it is mapped into the server address space as well
by the, by the kernel and since only the A stack
is mapped into the address space of both the
client and the server. If this has pointers pointing to
the other parts of the client address space, so it
is not going to be a, able to access that. So,
it is important that the arguments are passed by value
and not by by reference. And the work done by
the stub in, in preparing the array stack is much
simpler than what I told you earlier about. The general
RPC mechanism of creating an RPC packet. Where
it has to serialize the data structures that
are being passed as arguments. In this case,
it is simply copying the arguments from the
stack of the client thread into this A stack. That's what is being done by this
stub. Then the client traps into the kernel,
making a procedure called s.foo that is also
in the trap. And, at this point, the the client's stop is presenting through the
kernel the binding object associated with s.foo.
So the binding object, I told you, is
the capability that this client is authorized
to make calls on s.foo. So once the
BO is validated by the kernel, it
can then see what the procedure descriptor associated
with the BO is. And this procedure descriptor
is, as I told you, the information that
is needed by the kernel in order to
pass the control to the server, to start executing
the server procedure corresponding to this particular RPC
call being made by the client. Now recall that
the semantics of RPC is that the client,
once it makes this RPC call, it's basically blocked.
It's waiting for the call to be complete
before it gets started resuming its execution. Therefore the
optimization, what the kernel could do is. Borrow
because all of this is happening on the same
machine the kernel can borrow the client thread
and doctor the client thread to run on the
server address place. Now what do I mean
by doctoring the client thread? What I mean is.
Basically what you want to do is you want
to make sure that the client's thread starts executing
in the address space of the server, and the
PC that the client thread is going to start executing
in is the entry point procedure that is pointed
to by the procedure descriptor. So you have the fix
of the PC. The address space descriptor, and the
stack that is being used by the server in order
to execute this entry-point procedure. And for this purpose, what
the kernel does is it allocates a special stack, which
is called the execution stack, I'm not showing you this
picture. An execution stack, or E-Stack, and that is a
stack that the server procedure is going to use. In
order to do its own thing, because server procedure may
be making it's own procedure calls and so on, so
it's going to do all of that action on the E-stack.
So the A-stack is only for the purpose of passing the arguments, and the E-stack
is what the server is going to use in order to make, do its own work.